[Music]
[Applause]
i'm wondering
is this on oh perfect yeah yeah
great no thank you very much thanks for
the intro and
uh i have to admit i feel quite
inadequate with my slide decks after
watching everybody else's however if you
want tips around how to have two columns
in a slide io
i have a solution for you so so anyways
uh
no i just want to basically start by
saying i don't know if
you guys attended the keynote speaker by
keynote speech by jj um wasn't that the
most awesome
keynote speech i i was getting
teary-eyed you know it's uh
i don't know if it was me or not i was
almost it was one of those things that
you're trying to hide like
you know cleaning your eyes so so
anyways
um so yeah my name is nima nima safayan
uh
so our panda training solution is
simulator for commodity asset
optimization
so a little bit about us you know when i
was kind of
preparing for this talk i don't know to
what extent you can see or pictures
there
um but um when i was getting ready for
this talk you know um
i had a bit of a dilemma you know um
do i get technical talk about or
solutions or um or talk about you know
the busine
the business that we're in in general
and kind of tell you about our idea and
the concept so the tip
i got from a good friend was that no you
know people people here they know about
r they know about uh shiny spend your
time talking about
uh the business you're in and uh
talk talk about you know the solution
that you're you're providing
so we are a um so i'm gonna get into it
this is a
side project for us however uh we have
registered it as a company in uh
kelowna bc so if you're familiar with
where clonai is it's actually not that
far from here
that's almost like uh british columbia's
answer to napal valley i mean it's not
as nice but
it's it's it's good it's good for us and
we registered
the company there and it was kind of
over a
couple of bottles of wine uh that me and
my business partner basically
decided that we need to get this going
um however both of us live in uh live
and work in calgary
um so a little bit about us uh so my
partner
uh he uh he has built
and expanded number of uh commodity
trading groups
uh working for uh bp energy trading uh
and then working for uh for a bank in in
canada
and he has done it globally and also in
canada i'm i'm currently
running a market analytics team in uh
for a company called synovus energy so
that's kind of my day job
um so within that day job we uh
you know we deal like in energy business
i don't know how much
how much in in this room you're familiar
with that
we deal with deal with quite a bit of
complexity so
so this is a leaflet map if i can get it
uh get it to work of um north american
oil infrastructure so
the dots you see the black dots you see
there are
refineries that are dotted in various
sort of what's called paths in u.s
and these are districts that have a
historical
reason for secure energy security and
defense
but however that's a way of kind of
looking at the
at the market and then what you see in
terms of green are all the oil pipelines
that bring
oil from production basins in
in canada in in texas to
to where the refineries are um
so so this is only oil infrastructure i
mean
if i overlaid for example natural gas
here
it would have been a quite a complicated
sort of map and it would have not
been that useful but but what i want to
highlight here
is energy business is a
complex business it's both
complex from a sort of systematic
perspective
because it has all sorts of moving parts
um
various assets different locations
but also it's dynamically complex
because it's exposed to a lot of
exogenous shocks
for example you know right now what's
topical is chronovirus
so chronovirus uh in asia has a
has had a significant impact on
perception
of change in jet fuel use
because the idea is that you know you're
basically
um you know you're not gonna people are
not gonna fly as much
so that has a cascading effect on oil
demand
on refinery utilization and
given that all these energies are
interconnected
that has an impact and an overall sort
of
stack of energies so so over the years
to kind of working in a trade shop that
actively trades these assets
um and uh and and energies
you kind of realize that you know
tools like excel wouldn't cut it anymore
so you have to
kind of go for something a little bit
more advanced
so um so i mean since
i think 2012 when i got introduced to r
i've been using that and deploying that
in my workplace
to effectively break down complexity
take a complex
problem
albeit in a trading analytics context
use visualizations use clustering use
machine learning
to create simple models that we can
we can basically use in order to
force an action or encourage an action
in terms of a trading position
um however though i mean
with with all of that uh
of those tools um and in fact like kind
of
it's a funny funny thing at in our in
our work just to give you a bit of a
perspective is
um when uh so people people kind of joke
and these are these are not necessarily
our users they joke that
you know when faced with a very
difficult business problem
they basically say oh we can we can hire
somebody
and give them excel and get them working
on it for
for a year or it's going to be four
lines of our code
so so that's kind of it's a bit of a
mystique around it
in in our workplace and it's a very uh
it's kind of interesting and i think
it's
it's a sentiment that's shared with a
lot of uh
by a lot of people in this conference
however though with simplifying that
complexity through data science you
still need traders
i mean we are not at a point that we can
kind of
automatically decide on risk reward
decisions
so you need you need you need that human
factor
and what makes a good trader is somebody
that can
scan the energy
environment find
signs of market dislocations um
and use optionality of their assets so
we're talking
not necessarily guys that do futures
trading but these are
asset traders so they basically go and
rent a tank or you know they basically
these are trade trade shops that own
refineries or
own transport assets such as pipelines
which which basically when you think
about it it's a
by itself it can be modeled as a option
it's an option to move one energy across
time meaning that you can store in one
one time period withdraw in a different
time period you can move energies
through location
let's say you know you basically move a
barrel of
crude oil from canada to texas
or you can change it in form so let's
say you can
use a refinery to to produce refined
products
so at any every of any of those steps
that you take there's an opportunity
to to capture and arbitrage
um so in some ways like you know when
you actually movie model that in
from a valuation perspective you're
looking at these as
um as a call option on a spread or a
spread option for for for those of you
who are uh
come from that quant background um so so
the traders
always are in the lookout for uh assets
that gives them the highest optionality
so so and and and their ability to
monetize these assets
is what makes them a good trader um and
some of these are
you know when you actually pick up pick
take a
pipeline commitment for example as an
oil company or a trade shop
you're actually looking at a long-term
commitment that
locks you in for for many years so so
there is a
level of consequence involved
with these decisions so so your ability
to actually see complexity
uh c c effectively signal through noise
and uh cut through complexity is is key
as a trader
so with that problem in mind uh
and and you know the other thing about
trading is like there is a misperception
i think that
some people are naturally good traders i
think it's a skill that can be
learned and in fact uh working for
some of the may big
trading company as part of a
multinational
oil company my past experience
you kind of realize that there's a bit
of a method to this madness in terms of
hiring teaching
and and training your uh your traders
and um and some companies do that
consistently and do that across the
board
which which kind of got us thinking
around you know
can we actually find develop a set of
tools with
assessment modules with training courses
that could actually codify some of that
some of those rules that would allow you
to select
good traders train them and uh
and and incorporate them into your into
your company so
so this is our first sort of i i kind of
put that as a
bit of a thing on that slide deck which
is
this is our first lean canvas for those
of you i've kind of
dealt with uh starting uh starting doing
a startup
sort of uh starting a startup where
we're actually participating in one of
these startup weekends that's one of the
things that they
they usually do so you basically have a
problem
so so the problem that we're trying to
solve our
uh trader competency assessment and
development
um and we're trying to solve that for
universities and uh
and later on for for corporations
and the solution that we provided that
we have been testing it over the past
past year are effectively three tools
and these tools are
developed in shiny because that's what
me and my business partner philip cote
are familiar with
so it kind of goes to tell you we are
not necessarily software developers but
we had an idea this is a very agile tool
we could basically
bring it to life and and also a whole
bunch of trading modules
and assessment frameworks that comes
with that
so one is a multi-day trader game where
uh
students currently in university of
alberta
they they basically participate in a
um basically one semester sort of
trading game they can trade uh
commodity futures and as part of their
curriculum
they learn how to do a proper market
call
learn about risk reward analysis learn
about energy assets and infrastructures
and then every week they basically put
on a trade which they
they go and try to explain to their
classmates
what the rationale of their trade is and
and they see the result by the end of
the semester they actually
um they get marked on the p l that they
accumulate
and and also the insights that has has
gone to their
um to their trading strategy
the other one that i'm going to demo
quickly here is our real-time trader
game
this is a one year of market data
condensed in 20
minutes so every every second is almost
like a day so it's a high stress
scenario that
people actually trade real assets
and then the finally the one that we're
kind of right now developing in a shiny
framework it's kind of
i guess offline right now is our
negotiation game that you
negotiate to purchase an asset um
and um and it's it's kind of like we're
trying to capture
a lot of the discussions that happens as
a in
in the process um so in terms of our
technology stack we have uh we rely
fully on open source um we're using
quite a bit of plumber api
so there's a lot of talks around plumber
api it's a
if you haven't used it it's one of the
best products that uh
that's out there um we have actually
developed and open sourced a lot of our
code these are helper tools that you
know helps you with
energy analysis sort of pre-trade
analysis
it's called rtl it is on github
currently
but as of yesterday we submitted it to
cut so so just a
thing of personal experience you know
those warnings you see when you create a
package
cran does not accept any of those
warnings so you have to be
very very it's it's probably one of the
most frustrating things
so oh wow so so quickly
i want to now uh go through my uh
simulation software so this is how it
looks like um
so you can trade futures um
you know it's it's all done in uh shiny
dashboard so you see like the
i'm using invalidate later quite a bit
uh to to kind of get this more reactive
or get this reactive so you can actually
look do on-the-fly analysis
um you can you can now go and uh
look at the news effectively the news
feed some of it is fake news some of it
is real
you can also see some of the um you know
the overall sort of how you're doing
in in your trades so i'm using gt table
for that
for if you're interested so you can go
and in this case you can go on
buy an asset so in this case you're
bidding on a pipeline
it gives you a coat based off of where
the market is trading at you go and
approve it
and now you have the asset that you can
trade
so so you can go and basically put a
position against it
so given that i'm running short in time
i'm not gonna
go through this in detail but uh but i'm
i'm gonna do it give you a real demo if
you wanna talk to me afterwards
so so scaling challenges was the biggest
thing you know up to
now i've kind of had experience using
shiny and r and i thought i had it
figured out until
i had to scale and use
invalidate later so so basically
our experience was after 10 users we
almost hit a limit
so what we did was we kind of went and
followed the best practice which i'm
kind of lying on that one we did not do
that
so we effectively
we through brute force we tried to add
more cpus and didn't work
so then i have again i relied on my good
friend
in our studio who connected me with our
studio engineers
and they basically put some sense into
me in terms of my
code design so uh so the things the
takeaways
use uh profits
shiny cannon use it early and often
uh you can debug your code standalone
for one user
it doesn't mean that you can scale it do
not read and write to disk
do not use ggplot use
something like plotly which is
javascript base
and then finally you know you have
there's lots of talks here on
you know how to scale things i wish i
actually attended this conference last
year
so what's next for us we're expanding uh
our
platform to more universities we want to
have a global competition so scaling is
important for us
we are incorporating nlp and
learning algorithms reinforcement
learning in particular
to actually uh start not only to collect
a lot of
a lot more data which is in terms of
chat and text that peop
traders are actually conducting among
themselves but also
to play this game in conjunction with a
human trader
to understand what good looks like and
also
incorporate maybe features that nudge
traders in terms of
making better decisions so almost like
you know your drive assist in your car
um so so yeah that's that's kind of my
that sums up my presentation thank you
very much for your attention
thank you nema uh i've got just one
question at the moment but if you have
more questions please add them to uh to
slido we've got
time for just a couple um have you tried
uh
training an ai model to trade
commodities
um that's that's an interesting one
that's that's what we are trying to do
using reinforcement learning
um uh we haven't no
so that's our next to do effectively
going forward
okay thank you very much neil thank you
very much